les protagonistes de ce film était à
l'époque invisible à nous rapportions à
staline où nous en étions pour effectuer
des essais ils ne sont pas habitués à
s'exprimer publiquement
staline a demandé si au lieu d'une seule
bombe
on pouvait en faire deux moins puissante
pour qu'il y en ait deux et non une
seule
leurs vies étaient classés top secret
d'où les pauses dans leurs paroles
ils choisissent leurs mots avec soin
j'ai dit que c'était impossible
tout n'a pas encore été racontée ce film
revient sur les histoires des
scientifiques et agents du renseignement
qui ont participé à la création de la
première bombe nucléaire soviétique
une tâche urgente pour un pays dévasté
par la guerre est menacée par la mpt
nucléaire américaine
[Musique]
avant la guerre
les physiciens soviétique évoque déjà
l'énergie nucléaire des innovateurs
audacieux ont découvert l'un des secrets
de la structure de la matière la fission
spontanée de l'uranium dans les années
1920 nicolaï semionov physiciens de
leningrad développe une base théorique
des réactions en chaîne
à peu près au même moment il remarque un
jeune physicien ils oublient qu'à riton
et l'invite à travailler dans son
laboratoire et là un curieux article
attire l'attention du jeune chercheur en
allemagne travaillent une très bonne
chimiste idan odac elle critique et l'un
des articles de fermi mais il ne lui est
pas venu à l'esprit qu'au moment d'une
telle fission il pourrait y avoir une
réaction en chaîne
en gros une explosion nucléaire ce n'est
que cinq ans plus tard pour commencer
les véritables travaux sur l'explosion
nucléaire
je travaille à presque simultanément
commencé aux états unis en russie et en
angleterre
c'était en 1939 en europe se passe
beaucoup de choses
l'allemagne annexes l'autriche en 1938
après les accords de munich est
l'allemagne s'empare des sudètes
pendant ce temps les physiciens année
strassmann découvre qu'un noyau
d'uranium bombardée par un neutron se
divise en deux particules radioactives
et débloque une grande quantité
d'énergie
plusieurs scientifiques soviétiques de
l'époque étudiait le même phénomène dont
scopelleti pétriacq tam et yoff fille
aurore est rousse innove travailler sur
la même question dans le laboratoire du
jeune docteur en physique
gore kurchatov
notamment mais il ne s'agissait pas de
créer une bombe nucléaire
il s'agissait seulement d'une importante
expérience scientifique ball chaume
censé révolutionner la science
l'industrie et l'économie nationale
amnistie
même si à l'étranger elle était déjà
question de créer des explosifs
nucléaires surpuissant les physiciens
elle dovic écart it on prouve
théoriquement la probabilité d'une
réaction en chaîne et arrive à la
conclusion que la fission nucléaire d'un
kg d'uranium débloquerait autant
d'énergie que la détonation de plusieurs
milliers de tonnes de l'explosif le plus
puissant tout ceci a des allures de film
d'espionnage
mais c'est la réalité il est rare pour
des scientifiques ou pour des agents de
renseignement de s'exprimer de manière
aussi directe
je suis un peu une tête brûlée et j'ai
mon caractère
profil leonid romanovitch grèce nikov
nom de code
anton il rejoint les services de
renseignement en 1938 il est directeur
adjoint de l'unité de renseignement
scientifique et technique entre 39 et 42
entre 43 et 45 il est résident à new
york
il dirige les efforts visant à infiltrer
le projet manhattan
le programme nucléaire américain
[Musique]
en août 1941 le chef du renseignement
extérieur de l'urss pavel fit in reçoit
un mémo de leonid kogan nikov ce mémo
l'informent que toute mention de
découvertes dans le domaine de la
fission nucléaire et tous les noms des
physiciens nucléaires ont disparu des
sources en libre accès en allemagne en
angleterre au canada et aux états unis
mais toute nouveauté m'intéresse j'ai
envoyé le télégramme suivant des travaux
sont en cours sur une possible
utilisation de l'énergie nucléaire à des
fins militaires
à la demande du chef du renseignement
que valve nikov prépare une directive
pour tous les bureaux étrangers
ordonnance ceci accorder une attention
particulière aux projets du
développement d'armes de destruction
massive comme tout se passait vite cette
directive a été publié
profil vladimir borissov itx markovski
nom de code
jerry docteur en histoire travail dans
le renseignement depuis 39 est envoyé à
londres en 41
le bureau de londres était le premier à
réagir à la directive
le premier agent qui a répondu et et
mclean il apporter un ensemble de
dossiers du comité de l'uranium tâche
était de préparer la production d'armes
atomiques en angleterre le renseignement
soviétiques traverse une période
difficile
les structures de la sécurité de l'état
ont été épuisés par une série de purges
juste avant la guerre en 1938
aucun message n'a été envoyée aux
organes dirigeants du pays par le
renseignement pendant 127 jours le
service de renseignement avaient subi
tant de purges qu'il n'y avait personne
pour signer les documents à transmettre
aux autorités supérieures
le commissaire du peuple à la sécurité
d'état nicolaï et chauffe se vante même
d'avoir purgé 14 mille tchékistes
l'agent résidents de new york a été
rappelé et fusillé en 1938 le chef de
l'unité chargée de ces questions a été
condamné en tant qu ennemi du peuple et
le chef des services de renseignement
pas sauf que je connaissais
personnellement aussi a été arrêté et
exécuté pour remplacer les tchékistes
purgé de la garde de lénine les
structures de la sécurité d'état emploie
800 jeunes recrues en 1938 a été prise
la décision de l'appel des membres de la
jeunesse communiste et du parti dans les
rangs du renseignement parti ne me
plaisait on recrutait des jeunes hommes
qui avaient été élevés à l'époque
soviétique ou et qu'ils avaient eu leur
diplôme universitaire à l'époque
soviétique
en conséquence pendant les années
d'avant guerre quelques 200 agents
travaillaient dans près de 40 bureaux de
renseignement à l'étranger le bureau de
londres a repris son travail considéré
comme un nid des ennemis du peuple
il avait été fermé en 1939 sur ordre de
veria le premier agent résidents
anatolie gorski est arrivée seulement en
novembre 1940 profil anatolie benyamine
ovitz gorski nom de code
vadim travaillent dans les services de
sécurité de l'état depuis vingt-huit
envoyés au bureau de londres en 36 ans
il est nommé agent résidents il
travaille avec les cinq de cambridge
l'un d'eux lui transmet les premiers
matériaux sur la bombe nucléaire
imaginez cette scène au bureau je suis
assis en train d'examiner mes papiers
gorsky qui est revenu d'une réunion
examine ses papiers il se tourne vers
moi et me dit écoute tu es ingénieurs
ici j'ai des données techniques analyse
ça et prépare un télégramme de synthèse
borkowski envoie le télégramme
les physiciens soviétique était déjà au
courant du problème
après un rapport d'igor coach a tough à
l'académie des sciences
un document est publié avec un possible
schéma de la bomba
igor kurchatov a publié entre 1933 et
1946 heures oeuvre brillante sur la
physique nucléaire qui lui ont permis
d'envoyer en 1940 au présidium de
l'académie des sciences et au
gouvernement ce programme où il
annonçait la possibilité d'effectuer une
réaction nucléaire en chaîne
peu de temps après le bureau de londres
commence à envoyer des rapports
inquiétants sur des réunions secrètes du
comité de l'uranium
ce mémo est le premier document
déclassifié sur les questions nucléaires
il y a eu d'autres messages avant celui
là tous estampillés secret archives
top secret en septembre 1941
gorsky rapporte depuis londres que lors
d'une réunion du comité britannique
il a été annoncé qu'une bombe à
l'uranium pourrait être créé d'ici deux
ans et quand plus d'un énorme effets
destructeurs de la bombe à uranium
après la détonation l'air serait enrichi
de particules radioactives capable de
tuer tout être vivant
subissant l'activité de ces particules
nous avons dû activer énormément pour
restaurer le réseau d'agents le plus
rapidement possible voilà pourquoi une
semaine après mon arrivée à londres
le résident marois y ait rencontré mon
premier agent je n'avais jamais vu
d'agents en personne avant je savais
seulement qu'ils existaient et comment
on pouvait travailler avec eux nous
avons dû prendre des risques car la
guerre était proche et nous n'avions pas
de réseau alors je suis allé à cette
adresse
la moitié du bâtiment avaient disparu
parce qu'il y avait une frappe aérienne
allemande peu de temps auparavant une
bombe a frappé cette maison en
particulier j'ai décidé d'aider une
vieille dame en sortir quelque chose
traiter les vôtres au ont vécu ici aussi
j'ai demandé c'est qu'il est notre nom
des réfugiés européens comme vous où
sont ils maintenant sont-ils en vie et
en bonne santé
on les a transférés là-bas dans une
autre maison j'y suis allé et je les
trouvais il m'a littéralement serrer
dans ses bras
où avez vous été pendant toutes ces
années
l'armée rouge bat en retraite subissant
de lourdes pertes de violentes batailles
font rage non loin de moscou
le haut commandement n'a pas de temps à
consacrer aux physiciens béria a étudié
les rapports de londres mais ne les
croit pas pour l'instant ils pensent que
c'est une ruse pour tromper les
dirigeants soviétiques
des informations erronées ont été
envoyés pour désorienter les
scientifiques et l'industrie les
ressources et la main d'oeuvre pour
qu'ils se concentrent sur un problème
éphémère dans le premier département du
nkvd un nouveau dossier apparaît nom de
code est normal de nombreux documents de
ce dossier sont toujours classés secrets
là je vous dis vite à l'offshore votre
cas c'est surprenant à quel point ce nom
convenait aux renseignements nucléaire
pour enormous c'est quelque chose
d'énorme de terrifiantes et en date
concernant les armes nucléaires elles
mêmes sont terrifiantes dans leurs
applications
mais l'opération elle-même était énorme
nos îles samoa p razzano
[Musique]
à l'automne 1941 le physicien allemand
klaus fuchs qui travaillaient sur le
projet nucléaire en angleterre offre ses
services aux diplomates soviétiques à
londres plus tard un autre physicien
anglais spécialiste en nucléaire propose
également son aide
son nom n'a toujours pas été révélé
barco ce qui commence à travailler avec
fuchs et les dirigeants soviétiques sont
mises au courant du projet nucléaire
britannique
quant à cet homme qui a voulu nous aider
volontairement
il fallait voir qui ils étaient si ils
étaient fiables
il s'est avéré être bienveillant et
amicales mais quand il a commencé à me
raconter avec enthousiasme quelque chose
sur la section de capture des neutrons
par les atomes d'uranium 235
il a fait une pause et m'a demandé où je
vois que vous ne comprenez rien de ce
que je dis
à ce moment là je voulais proposer ce
qui me paraissait une option simple mais
brillante
je vais vous poser les questions de nos
physicien vous y répondez et j'enverrai
les réponses il a dit non ça n'ira pas
comme ça allez dans une librairie et
acheter un manuel américain intitulé la
physique nucléaire appliquée nous allons
travailler sur ce manuel ensemble et
après je crois tout sera clair
la grande-bretagne conclut qu'il faut
impliquer l'allié américain
les laboratoires britanniques sont à
portée de tir de l'aviation allemande et
l'économie britannique ne peut financer
un projet nucléaire aussi coûteux à
partir de ce moment les efforts du
renseignement soviétiques porte sur les
secrets américains profil anatoli
antonov beach yade skov nom de code
alexei rejoint les services de
renseignement en 39 affecté au bureau de
new york avant la seconde guerre
mondiale en 1941
nous n'avions pas de sources aux états
unis nous devions nous en occuper
d'urgence mais trouver des personnes qui
nous donnerait ces informations fin 1943
et début 1944
nous avons trouvé ces personnes il faut
noter que ces gens ne touchait pas un
sou pour leur travail
personne n'a jamais eu un seul kopeck un
seul centime de niang et il y avait bien
une telle conspiration une gigantesque
conspiration je connaissais très bien
markovski je connaissais yade score
j'avais rencontré couach nikos
c'étaient tous des gens descendent
modèle je leur ai parlé à moscou si
j'envoyais un agent en amérique
je venais voir yade sports il était le
chef du département
on se rencontraient pour discuter des
questions opérationnelles l'auteur
staline comprend que la bombe nucléaire
n'est pas une ruse ont la forme qu'un
étrange caillé a été trouvé sur le corps
de l'officier allemand hans vandervelde
tué près de taiwan rogge
il contient des formules des dessins
techniques des calculs les experts
soviétiques ayant examiné le cas liée
estime que selon ces notes
l'allemagne vise à utiliser l'énergie
nucléaire à des fins militaires
l'officier décédé cherchaient
probablement des gisements d'uranium en
russie
le temps presse le 28 septembre 42 le
comité d'état de la défense publie
l'ordre numéro 23 52 sur l'organisation
des travaux sur l'uranium qui prévoit la
création du laboratoire numéro 2 connue
aujourd'hui sous le nom d'institut
kurchatov
il n'a pas dit si cette pièce nous
sommes maintenant dans une maison une
maison musée unique en son genre celle
de l'académicien kurchatov ou igor
kurchatov a vécu les 14 dernières années
de sa vie à partir de 1943 et à
travailler à ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
l'institut kurchatov où se trouve cette
maison au cours de ses deux premières
années il vivait dans le bâtiment
principal où se trouve toujours son
bureau administratif fin 40 de la
situation sur le front se stabilise et
l'armée rouge en cercle une importante
formation allemande près de stalingrad
une réunion a lieu au kremlin et staline
se rend compte qu'on ne peut se
permettre d'avoir du retard dans les
recherches sur l'uranium
il donne l'ordre de commencer
immédiatement le développement d'une
arme nucléaire soviétique
nous devons commencer trois mots
seulement c'est tout et qui sera en
charge
on a dit kurchatov il a répondu je ne
connais pas ce scientifique
n'avons nous pas des universitaires
digne de confiance qui pourrait
s'occuper de cette affaire
elio fait a dit je ne peux pas je ne
pourrais pas organiser ça et pousser les
choses plus loin alors que kurchatov
pourrait le faire à mon avis
alors staline a répondu est bien
d'accord que ce soit lui sous votre
responsabilité
[Musique]
pour plaisanter ses amis appellent
kurchatov la barbe ou général pour son
grand coeur et ses talents
d'organisateur
il mobilise les meilleurs scientifiques
du pays tous les physiciens nucléaires
ont été retirés du front pour travailler
sur le nouveau projet à l'époque je
travaillais à sverdlovsk dans l'oural
j'ai été invité à venir à moscou de
manière assez inattendue
j'y suis allé immédiatement
nous savions que la tâche serait
difficile
nous avons dû faire face à une série de
calculs et de tests les expériences ont
montré que le problème était tout à fait
possible à résoudre bien que très
difficiles techniquement et
scientifiquement
cependant nous avons décidé de nous
fixer un but et de l'accomplir une fois
kurchatov m'a appelé et a demandé de me
rencontrer je viendrai chez vous at il
promis
j'ai répondu vous pouvez venir
maintenant il est venu et a dit que les
travaux sur le développement d'armes
nucléaires allait bientôt commencer vous
allez travailler sur un certain nombre
de projets dans ce domaine
je vous propose de vous lancer
directement la création de la bombe
nucléaire est le même
c'était en 1943 jokin j'ai dit écoutez
je pense qu'il faut peut-être se
concentrer sur les travaux qui sont
directement liés à la guerre en ce
moment n'est-il pas encore trop tôt il a
répondu non nous devons commencer à
travailler dans ce sens également
[Applaudissements]
le département du renseignement commence
à transmettre toutes les informations
sur la bombe nucléaire directement à
courre chat of le 7 mars 1943 après
avoir reçu 17 pages de renseignements
kurchatov écrit un mémo daube secret la
réception de ces données a une
importance énorme et inestimable pour
notre état et la science goebbels par le
116 d'une arme allemande fantastique
qu'est ce que c'est des missiles v2 ou
s'agit-il vraiment d'une bombe nucléaire
gay games jackass est sans arrêt à la
radio tous les journaux écrivent et il
va y avoir une arme miraculeuse il
parlait d'un missile annonçant que von
braun créerait un missile qui pourrait
atteindre les états unis c'était le rêve
de von braun créer un missile qui
pourrait non seulement frappé londres
pour top scorer l'état mais aussi frappé
new york
c'était ça cet art miraculeuse et si la
guerre avait duré deux ans de plus van
den brande l'aurais fait mais on
découvrira cela beaucoup plus tard à ce
moment là les alliés ne s'empresse pas
de partager avec l'union soviétique
leurs plans où les résultats de leurs
travaux sur une bombe à l'uranium
ce sont les renseignements qu'ils
informent kurchatov du fait que les
états unis ont lancé leur premier
réacteur nucléaire l'été 43 et de
l'intention des états unis de créer une
bombe chargée d'autres matières
le plutonium son numéro dans le tableau
de mendeleïev et le 94
on ne le trouve pas dans la nature
voici une lettre de kourtchatov appert
bookeen ministre de l'industrie chimique
daté du 22 mars 43 la bombe sera donc
fabriqué à partir d'un matériel non
naturelle qui a disparu de notre planète
tout devait être vérifié tout exiger des
expériences tout nécessité des matériaux
totalement nouveau que nous n'avions pas
de masque on ne sait alors presque rien
des propriétés du plutonium son point de
fusion sa dureté etc
les services de renseignement sont alors
chargés de les découvrir
j'ai toujours été sous surveillance y
rencontrer les gens que je devais
rencontrer était toujours extrêmement
difficiles le plus souvent je le faisais
via des contacts intermédiaires ou une
organisation qui auraient pu être
utilisés comme couverture par exemple
semionov a toujours été pris en filature
profil senior markovic semionov nom de
code twain rejoint les services de
renseignement en 37 envoyé aux états
unis pour faire ses études om haïti en
38 serre entre 40 et 44 au sein du
bureau de new york dans le département
du renseignement scientifique et
technique
il s'occupe des armes nucléaires il
avait de bonnes relations avec divers
scientifiques
voilà pourquoi je les envoyais une
parfois deux voitures le suivait et
après ça ils disaient allez sacha vas-y
vas-y profil alexandre semionovitch fait
christophe 10h à nom de code cali
stratus rejoint le renseignement
soviétiques en 39 serre dans le bureau
de new york à partir de 41 chargé de
recueillir des informations sur
l'électronique l'aviation et le
nucléaire
affecté à londres en 47
c'est chaud ici chez christophe aller
rencontrer les mêmes agents que semionov
puis semionov a cessé de le faire petit
à petit et c'est fait cli sauf qu'ils
allaient à leur rencontre et le premier
lui servait de l'heure ou qu'est top
secret le 23 mars 1943 le colonel
hovaguimian chef du 3e département de la
première direction soviétique duhaime
kgb écrit selon des informations datant
approximativement d'avril mai de cette
année les changes de matériaux entre
l'angleterre et les états unis pour ce
qui concerne énorme oeuf a été arrêté et
des négociations sont en cours
les américains offrent aux anglais des
conditions d'une future coopération qui
donne aux américains un monopole absolu
temps militaire qu'industriel
[Musique]
le projet américain comprend un
laboratoire scientifique à los alamos
qui développe la construction de la
bombe nucléaire ainsi que trois usines
géantes de production de plutonium et
d'uranium 235
ces installations ont été construites à
des milliers de kilomètres de l'endroit
où nous étions stationnés dans des zones
à faible densité de population où
l'apparition d'un nom local ou d'un
nouveau résident attirer l'attention
les niveaux il était au centre de
l'attention et il ya eu deux cas où nos
coursiers ont été interrogées en 1944
coach a tough se plaint de l'absence de
base expérimentale il ne peut pas
toujours vérifié l'exactitude des
renseignements reçus en un an kurchatov
et son équipe ont reçu plus d'une
centaine de pages de textes et environ
800 clichés pour obtenir ces documents
certaines personnes risquent même leur
vie en août 1945 par exemple une jeune
femme se rend dans une petite station
balnéaire près de los alamos avec une
recommandation de médecins prescrivant
un traitement pulmonaire
profil léontine cohen dit lesley nom de
code
hélène kruger né aux états unis recruté
en tant qu agent soviétique en 41 par
son mari louis maurice cohen pour
travailler avec les services de
renseignement soviétique
[Musique]
léontine rencontre un scientifique
atomique venue de los alamos
il lui transmet des documents secrets
qu'elle cache dans une boîte de kleenex
à la gare des agents du fbi à une
fouille avec soin tous les passagers
léontine cohen ne cède pas à la panique
elle donne la boîte à l'inspecteur en
faisant semblant de chercher son billet
alors que le train est sur le point de
partir après avoir répondu à toutes les
questions et montrer son billet elle
monte dans le wagon comme si elle avait
oublié la boîte l'agent du fbi elle
rattrape léontine et lui rend sa boîte
sans regarder son contenu quelques jours
plus tard maurice cohen transmet ces
documents à moscou il ya eu quelques cas
où notre agent escorté quelqu'un c'était
à londres
et tout à coup s'ouvrent la mallette et
tous les documents secrets du ministère
des affaires étrangères s'envole heskey
et là arrive un policier et le policier
l'aide à ramasser les documents et à les
remettre dans la mallette qui a le plus
contribué à la création de la bombe
nucléaire soviétique
les scientifiques ou les agents secrets
nous avons toujours donné la priorité
aux scientifiques le renseignement ne
peut pas même si on apporte une bombe
atomique entière il faut quand même
comprendre comment elle marche n'est ce
pas il faut aussi la mettre en
production
tout cela est plus compliqué que
transmettre un document un croquis et
voilà vous devez comprendre la
technologie c'est un processus très
compliqué
les données du renseignement complète et
découverte des scientifiques russes dans
un document consacré aux données
secrètes reçu kurchatov décrit ce
document est d'un grand intérêt
en plus des méthodes et des schémas que
nous développons il montre des
opportunités que nous n'avions pas
encore envisagée
conclusion sur les renseignements reçus
du ncaa gb en mars 1945
les documents contiennent des notes
intéressante sur la question de l'
isolement de la matière pour la bombe
atomique
elles correspondent aux conclusions
auxquelles nous sommes arrivés ces
derniers temps au moment où nous étions
prêts à commencer à travailler
sérieusement
nous avons reçu des informations sur la
conception d'une bombe atomique
après avoir discuté de la situation avec
bien sûr la participation de kourtchatov
nous avons décidé qu'il fallait reporter
notre invention à un peu plus tard on ne
pouvait pas négliger une telle
opportunité
on ne nous aurait tout simplement pas
permis de le faire
vous pouvez bien imaginer ce qui se
serait passé si notre première
expérience dans cette affaire avaient
échoué la plupart des installations
nucléaires et des réacteurs construits
en urss selon d'été sans obtenus par les
agents sont alors supérieur aux
originaux les américains qui ont visité
les centrales nucléaires russes n'ont
reconnu un demi siècle plus tard des
documents déclassifiés montre que des
agents ont réussi à expédier en urss des
échantillons d'uranium 235 il y a même
une légende selon laquelle moscou aurait
reçu un échantillon de plutonium
c'est une fois il a été annoncé qu'ils
avaient volé un peu de plutonium en
amérique et l'avait envoyé ici
beria l'a envoyé voir you licari ton
mais après vérification il s'est avéré
qu'il s'agissait d'uranium pur les noms
de plutonium
les travaux avancent vite a los alamos
le 25 avril 45 le ministre américain de
la guerre annoncent à truman que la
bombe pourrait exploser début juillet
seuls 10 des 150000 personnes qui
travaillent sur le projet manhattan
connaissent le but ultime
les conversations téléphoniques sont
écoutés les scientifiques nucléaires les
plus importants ont des gardes du corps
personnels des scientifiques des
etats-unis de grande-bretagne
d'allemagne et du canada dont douze prix
nobel travaille à la création de la
bombe
le système automatique de contrôle est
en marche
cette fois robe les enjeux sont élevés
on va marcher comme prévu robert et je
suis sûr que nous ne le regretteront pas
eh bien nous le serons dans 40 secondes
[Musique]
le 17 juillet 45 lors de la conférence
de postdam truman reçoit un télégramme
l'enfant est bien née
l'essai d'une bombe atomique à alamo
gordo au nouveau mexique est la veille a
réussi
les etats-unis ont désormais une super
bombe comment l'annoncer à staline il
est décidé que truman s'en chargerait
churchill s'en souvient ainsi j'étais
probablement à cinq mètres je suivais de
près c'est important de conversation je
savais ce que le président allait dire
il était extrêmement important de savoir
quelle impression cela ferait sur
staline
je revois la scène comme si c'était hier
un peu plus tard en attendant sa voiture
churchill s'approche de truman comment
tout cela s'est passé
ai-je demandé il n'a pas posé une seule
question a répondu le président je me
disais donc que staline n'était pas au
courant de l'énorme projet de recherches
effectuées par les états unis et la
grande bretagne
churchill n'a alors que partiellement
raison staline c'est tout mais il ne
s'imagine pas la force destructrice de
la nouvelle arme le bombardement des
villes japonaises vont le réveiller près
d'un demi million de personnes ont été
tuées ou blessées par les explosions de
hiroshima et de nagasaki
c'était une démonstration de force face
à l'urss achats vachon l'utilisation de
larmes par les américains à hiroshima et
nagasaki a été un chagrin
les essais sont une chose
ce que les scientifiques disent c'est
autre chose que les camps de vives sont
pratiquement effacé de la surface de la
terre
quand trois cent mille personnes
disparaissent d'un coup on comprend
soudain à quel point cette arme est
effrayante
notre call strache rouge
staline a compris le message le pays
victorieux dévasté par la guerre doit à
nouveau se battre pour survivre ils
exigent que scientifique et agents du
renseignement créé une bombe avant des
bus 48 les etats-unis ont entouré notre
pays de bases militaires
toute la presse américaine désignée des
images ou des avions volaient depuis ses
bases vers nos villes et centres
industriels avec des bombes atomiques à
bord c'était une question de vie ou de
mort pour notre pays de créer une arme
nucléaire qui puisse servir de réponse
désormais ils travaillent 24 heures sur
24 à la création d'une bombe
le 20 août 1945 et créer la première
direction principale auprès du conseil
des ministres soviétique dans le but
d'organiser l'industrie nucléaire du
pays
un second comité spécial est également
mise en place dirigé par béria c'est là
que tout a vraiment commencé
je vais décret précisé en outre que le
comité n'étaient responsables devant
personne
il a touché tous ils disposaient de très
important pouvoir je ne serai pas un
hasard si béria prenez une fois par
semaine tous les documents et
résolutions et les apporter à staline
pour signature
on trouve un site pour des recherches
secrètes la petite ville de sarov
éloignés du centre
il y a une usine de munitions et
plusieurs colonies pénitentiaires
les meilleurs physiciens mathématiciens
et ouvriers du pays sont réunis à sarov
mais staline n'est pas content le 25
janvier 1946 il veut pour la première
fois rencontré coach a tough béria et
molotov sont également présents staline
veut que les travaux soient menés à une
plus grande échelle à la russe il promet
tout ce qui sera nécessaire
beria et molotov reste silencieux tous
les efforts du pays ruiné par la guerre
sont mis dans le projet nucléaire
[Musique]
chat a raconté n'avoir vu staline que
deux fois comme ça on m'a tuer au tout
début et la veille de l'essai de la
bombe bombe aux noix mais je pense que
les documents ont été détruits
délibérément n'ont jamais été mentionné
je tombe pour que cette affaire reste
toujours classifiées biscalux cette
année là on trouve suffisamment
d'uranium exposés aux neutrons ce
dernier forme l'agent explosif d'une
bombe atomique
le plutonium quatre modèles de réacteurs
nucléaires sont assemblés et démonter
nécessitant des dizaines de tonnes
d'uranium et des centaines de tonnes de
graphite
le 25 décembre 1946 à moscou concha
tough lance avec succès le premier
réacteur nucléaire de ghazi lorsque
notre premier réacteur le f1 était en
construction sur un site à environ 300
mètres de nous on a mené une sorte de
levure des minuteries tiff pour redonner
des forces aux gens qui travaillaient à
l'assemblage du premier réacteur entre
16 et 18 heures par jour chemin ils ont
dû creuser des normes fausse les
renforcer avec du béton il fallait
déposer 500 tonnes de grafite pure et
environ 50 tonnes d'uranium pur dans cet
énorme voets ferrique en béton aux hedge
toi ton les déposer en conformité avec
des règles spécifiques que les
scientifiques avaient calculé avec des
grives notre fils on en pose et 5 aces
et seulement à la 5ème que notre
réaction nucléaire en chaîne commence à
oxford où la bête
c'est un succès grâce aux réacteurs sont
obtenus 23 microgrammes de plutonium une
quantité suffisante pour développer la
technologie d'extraction et construire
des usines de production de plutonium
pour les mots uranium plutonium isotopes
fils il n'existait pas
boutique il y avait des mots comme
oiseau ou fleurs selon la saison ont
publié un papier avec les codes pour
faire référence à tel ou tel matériel
utilisé dans le projet en 1947 klaus
fuchs membres du projet manhattan
revient des états unis en angleterre
le contact est rétablie avec lui voici
comment alexandre fait qui sauf décrit
cette rencontre je n'oublierai jamais
notre rencontre dans un pub une
brasserie je le surveillais de l'autre
côté de la route
j'avais une photo de lui je les ai vus
entrer jour je me suis assuré que
personne entrer tout de suite après lui
qu'il n'était pas surveillée je suis
entré environ deux minutes plus tard et
je l' ai vu il était assis nous avons
échangé un regard
nous nous sommes reconnus comme vos
fourneaux deux ans patron depuis comme
convenu il est allé vers le bar sur aube
où il y avait beaucoup de photos de
boxeur les gens avaient l'habitude de
discuter de leurs mérites
il s'est approché d'un groupe de trois
ou quatre personnes et rester là à
regarder et à écouter puis je me suis
approché il a prononcé notre code
je pense que bruce woodcock a été le
meilleur poids lourds de grande-bretagne
de tous les temps et il a quitté le pub
que bolton
ne l'est pas suivi tout de suite vous
plais seulement regarder par la fenêtre
pour voir dans quelle direction ils
allaient cool pour l'automne prochain
personne ne l'a suivi in town of je me
suis dirigé vers le bar j'ai donné un
pourboire au barman et je suis parti
pour ton pu les rattraper
je les ai arrêté et j'ai dit bonjour
klaus je suis heureux de te rencontrer
il a répondu moi aussi je pensais que
vous m'aviez oublier pendant ce temps
les états unis élaborent de nombreux
plans de frappe nucléaire contre des
villes soviétiques les opérations
totality pinscher ciseaux et de chat
nous lisions des plans publiés par
l'armée américaine après la guerre alors
que churchill nourrissait des projets de
frappe sur nos troupes
stockton et que les américains envisagé
de lancer des armes nucléaires sur nos
villes sur moscou leningrad et d'autres
ce sont des faits j'ai vu les documents
moi même temps le renseignement a mis la
main sur un grand nombre de projets
notamment totality cisl et peut-être le
projet le plus connu ce drop shot qui a
vu le jour et a été développé en 1949 il
a été finalisé en 1950 il prévoyait plus
de 300 frappes nucléaires sur tout le
territoire de l'union soviétique
territory 250 objets ont été désignés
comme cibles de bombardements nucléaires
allant jusqu'à 5 6 ou 7 frappe devait
être opéré sur les grandes villes
[Musique]
mais les scientifiques soviétiques sont
de plus en plus proche de réaliser leurs
objectifs à londres fait qu'ils sauvent
surprendre de plus en plus klaus fuchs
par la profondeur de ces questions
nikon cette rencontre m'a énormément
marqué c'était en 1948 je crois en
novembre il a commencé comme ça comme le
coach l'équipe de kourtchatov avance à
toute vitesse vers son objectif
j'ai demandé quel objectif il a répondu
le bébé va bientôt naître et il fera
entendre sa voix j'ai ajouté
je ne sais pas je vous ai toujours dit
que je n'étais pas quelqu'un de très
expérimenté
je me connais un peu en radio technique
ou en électronique
je suis diplômé de l'institut il a
répondu mais je vois quelles questions
vous poser et à partir de ces questions
je peux dire qu'elle est le stade de
développement
on se rencontre et comme ça c'était
difficile surtout quand il ne venait pas
au rendez vous au tombeau c'était un
tourment infernale je me demandais
toujours pourquoi ils ne venaient pas
peut-être que quelque chose de grave
était arrivé peut-être qu'ils avaient
été suivies ou pire arrêtées dont
comptant dans leurs rangs
plus tard j'ai appris qu'il était parti
de manière inattendue aux états unis
dans le cadre d'une délégation
britannique pour participer à des
pourparlers
puis il est revenu il était le troisième
physicien nucléaire le plus important
après le chef d'harwell endroits où la
bombe nucléaire britannique était
développé et l'adjoint de ce dernier il
était chef du département théorique ou
tout seul a été développé bien sûr je
lui demandais klaus comment tu arrives à
sortir les documents si un agent de
sécurité arrêter et demander pourquoi
vous emporter ces documents et il a
répondu avec un sourire je répondrais
très simplement que personne ne me l'a
interdit
je travaille chez moi je travaille 24
heures sur 24
quand on bien et je lui ai demandé j'ai
klaus pourquoi tu ne te marie pas tu
devrais sa réponse a été je sais quand
vous rencontrant je marche sur un champ
de mines un faux pas et on y passe tout
c'était dangereux
[Musique]
les etats-unis eux se demandent quand
les soviétiques auront leurs propres
bombes nucléaires
l'ingénieur nucléaire jon ogg hatton et
l'ancien conseiller sur l'économie russe
ellsworth raymonde sont convaincus que
si les russes réussissent ce ne sera pas
avant 54 ou 56 après la guerre
l'économie soviétique n'est tout
simplement pas à la hauteur
les soviétiques sont loin derrière la
recherche américaine et n'ont pas de
centrales électriques puissantes mais
soudain les américains détecte dans
l'atmosphère des traces résiduelles
radioactive d'une bombe nucléaire qui a
explosé le 29 août 1949 sur le site
d'essai de semih palatine sq la bombe a
été placée sur une tour à une hauteur
d'environ 30 mètres on a appuyé sur le
bouton et tout a été éclairée par une
lumière aveuglante
trente secondes plus tard l'ondé de choc
frappé après cela on pouvait sortir
béria était également dans le bunker
avec nous il a embrassé kurchatov et moi
sur le front nous étions sortis et
pouvions voir un nuage un champignon il
est clair que l'explosion avait été
assez puissante
les qualifications de nos scientifiques
n'était pas inférieure à celle des
scientifiques américains alors qu'ils
ont réuni des physiciens du monde entier
fait
après l'essai de semih palatine sq coach
à tort écrit au ministère de la sécurité
d'état
les services de renseignement ont
apporté une aide précieuse à la création
de l'armé nucléaire cela nous a
probablement fait gagner en jeu
peut-être un peu plus qui c'est
difficile à dire les scientifiques
nucléaires soviétiques ont travaillé dur
et de manière désintéressée pendant de
nombreuses années sur les ordres du
parti et du gouvernement
d'abord pour créer puis pour
perfectionner des armes atomiques et des
armes à hydrogène
parce que nous savions que l'état était
menacée et que si nous n'avions pas de
telles armes des forces chercherait à
mettre notre grande patrie à genoux nos
spécialistes ingénieurs et scientifiques
ont rempli leur devoir envers le pays
[Musique]
je
le projet nucléaire a énormément
stimuler le développement du pays
sur l'espace n'importe quelle technique
n'importe quels domaines de notre vie
aujourd'hui à d'une manière ou d'une
autre
débuté avec le projet nucléaire
soviétique un universitaire yves
guerrini avro rinne a fait une
observation curieuse en fait fabriquer
une bombe nucléaire est plus difficile
que d'aller sur mars
la nuance c'est que nous avons réussi à
créer cette bombe mais nous ne sommes
pas encore allés sur mars
nous devrions bien sûr être extrêmement
reconnaissants à fuchs ne connaissons
pas son nom personne ne nous disaient
d'où venaient ces informations son
identité a seulement été connue quand on
l'a jugée en 1950 il n'y avait pas qu'un
seul klaus fox
je pense qu'il y en avait environ une
dizaine d'hommes
de nombreux scientifiques il comprenait
la menace posée par l'impérialisme sans
foi ni loi des américains ce que l'on
observe encore parfaitement bien
aujourd'hui
regardez ce qu'ils font en irak en libye
n'importe quoi
ils ont tout mis sens dessus dessous
ils vont se retirer mais que laisseront
t-il derrière eux des ruines
[Musique]
je l' ai vu une fois mais c'était après
un certain nombre d'années dans une
prison anglaise kalisz sol est il y
avait d'autres personnes en plus de lui
mais je n'en parle jamais ce n'était pas
une ligne à dire deux ou trois personnes
qui nous transmettait des documents
[Musique]
je dois dire que j'ai les meilleurs
souvenirs possible de ces trente années
de collaboration avec kurchatov car
c'était toujours très intéressant d'être
avec lui il était toujours très vif
il aimait faire des blagues des farces
en même temps il repoussait toujours ses
limites au travail vous pouviez
littéralement voire de la vapeur
s'échapper de lui
[Musique]
son trait le plus étonnant était sa
capacité à attirer diverses personne
dotée d'une grande variété de qualités
professionnelles et humaines les
inspirant à vraiment mettre tout ce
qu'elle avait dans leur travail
le succès du projet peut être largement
attribuée au fer que ces cures chat off
qui le diriger notre pays chérira
toujours sa mémoire
nous devons beaucoup un corps chatr
igor kurchatov était un grand homme il a
vraiment assuré la sécurité de sa patrie
plus j'en apprends sur lui à partir de
petites notes plus j'apprécie le fait
que notre pays et des gens aussi
formidable possoni même s'ils sont pas
nombreux mais qui nous dit
les centaines de civils qui ont
participé aux essais nucléaires ont été
décorés neuf ont été décorés pour leur
participation au projet atomique ou la
construction du bouclier nucléaire
six agents du renseignement ont reçu le
titre de héros de la russie
[Musique]